welcome while I was just sent this
problem and I figure you can never get
enough practice getting the intuition
behind you know intervals of increase
decrease in inflection points and minima
and maxima so I'll do another problem
this was pretty interesting because it
has a natural log here so I thought I
would do this one so let's see it says f
of X with a big f Isla I liked you
better when it's lower case but f of X
is equal to the natural log of X to the
fourth plus 27 and find intervals of
increase decrease find intervals of
concavity and the inflection point so
before I delve into this problem let's
just make sure we understand what we're
going to do so find intervals of
increase or decrease so what are
intervals of increase that means the
slope is positive right if slope is
positive what does that mean increase so
intervals of increase means that the
slope is positive so that means that the
derivative is positive so that means
where does F prime of X where does that
eat where is that greater than zero
right increase intervals of increase is
just positive slope similar intervals of
decrease are just where f prime of x is
less than 0 the slope is negative that's
when the this this function is going to
decrease not not too not not too
sophisticated there now let's see five
the intervals of concavity and the
inflection points so what are those
intervals of concavity so just to review
of what we did before what where is the
where is the graph concave upwards so
I'll write that is concave con up what
where where is the graph concave upward
what does that look like that means if
the graph kind of looks like that well
that happens whenever what do we know to
be true the the slope itself is
increasing not just the graph is
increasing the slope itself is
increasing right because if the slope is
negative here it gets less negative then
it goes to 0 then it gets more positive
and then even more positive so concave
upwards means that the slope itself is
increasing which means the slope of the
slope is positive and what is the slope
of the slope well that's the second
derivative so that means that the second
derivative
of x is greater than zero and then
similarly concave downwards it's going
to look something like that the graphs
can look like that and that's when
that's periods of the curve where the
slope itself is decreasing right you
have a high slope here I think it's a
little bit flatter than goes to zero
then it's a little bit more negative so
that means that the slope of the slope
or the second derivative is decreasing
and what are inflection points
inflection points are points where you
go either from concave downward to
concave upwards or concave upwards to
concave downwards and they look like
this so if i was going from concave
upward to concave downward it would look
like this the graph would look like this
I'd be concave up and then I go concave
down and this point right here is where
you switched and that's an inflection
point or if you're going let's see if I
were to continue this graph I'm concave
down and then I would switch back to
concave up this point here would also be
an inflection point and at these points
since we're switching between concave up
and concave down or vice versa the
second derivative is zero soul all right
that inflection points inflection points
the second derivative is equal to zero
so let's use this bit of review to solve
this problem so intervals of increase
decrease so let's justwell let's take
just take the first of the second
derivative that's always a useful thing
to do so let's see f prime so let me
just write f of X we write in my own
handwriting to give me a little comfort
is equal to and maybe give you comfort
as well the natural log of X to the
fourth plus 27 what is the first
derivative F prime of X is equal to
let's do this chain rule some people go
outside in I do the inner expression
that I take the derivative of the whole
outside so what's the derivative of this
inside X to the fourth plus 27 well
that's just 4x to the third write the
derivative 27 is nothing times the
derivative of ln of this with respect to
this whole thing so what's what's the
derivative of ln of x it's 1 over X
right so the derivative of ln of this
whole thing with respect to this whole
thing
going to be equal to 1 over X to the
fourth plus 27 or you could say you know
that's the same thing as and I'm going
to write it this way just because I find
this easier in my head to grapple with
4x to the third times X to the fourth
plus 27 to the negative 1 power I like
doing it that because to take the
derivative second derivative now and
take the second derivative of this we
would have to know that the quotient
rule but now we just have to know the
product rule and I know the product rule
always forget the quotient rule so let's
do that let's take the second derivative
so f prime prime of X this might get a
little hairy the second derivative and I
will arbitrarily switch colors so let's
do the product rule so take the
derivative of the first expression the
first function so that's 12 x squared 12
x squared times the just the second
function times X to the fourth plus 27
to the negative 1 and then plus just the
first expression right we took the
derivative here so now we just take it
without the derivative here times the
derivative of the second thing and here
we're going to use the chain rule to
take the derivative of the second thing
so let's take the derivative of the
inside that's 4x to the third so it's x
4x to the third time's the derivative
this whole thing so let's say that's
negative 1 so x negative 1 x to the
fourth plus 27 to the negative 2 power
so that looks really really hairy but
let's see if we can if we can simplify
this a little bit so this is a hairy
problem clearly so this is equal to and
now since we have taken our derivatives
we can not write it as negative
exponents I think that'll make things a
little easier so that equals 12 x
squared over X to the fourth plus 27
plus or maybe I should say minus right
because it is minus x 4 x 4 so minus
let's see 4 times 4 is 16 and these are
multiplying X 3 X to the third X to the
sixth minus 16 X to the sixth overall of
that man this is messy over X to the
fourth plus 27 squared and now let's see
what we can do well hopefully this this
it been very cruel to send your problem
that doesn't have a clean answer but
let's keep chugging forward I think this
might end up clean and what is this
equal well let's find a common
denominator well this is X to the fourth
plus 27 this is that squared so the
common denominator is just that squared
it's a common denominator we write the
common denominator X to the fourth plus
27 and just so you know it's only
teachers or or that that will actually
give you this on homework you seldom see
something this here in exam but you
never know and that you definitely won't
see on the AP exam they're usually
testing concepts not your ability to
chug through a hairy problem but let's
see let's do it anyway it's never never
hurts so that's our common denominator
so this one is going to have to be that
the 12x squared times X to the fourth
plus 27 so 12x squared times X to the
fourth plus 27 and I hope that makes
sense to you right because think about
it if we just canceled this with the
squared you would end up with just this
term right there so all i did is i
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by X to the fourth plus 27
and then of course the second term
doesn't change because its denominator
was already this so minus 16 X to the
sixth now let me how let me just do
raise some of this stuff that I wrote up
here just cuz I I can't release this
because we're going to use this later so
but I think we're all almost almost
there so let me use the eraser tool
which is really just drawing a black box
and I think you remember all of this
stuff hopefully remember just so you
know I mean oftentimes when you're
chucking to the math you lose sight of
what we're even working on but we're
just trying to figure out the second
derivative and I'm just simplifying this
big hairy equation and that's actually
what this seems to be an exercise in and
simplification but let's I'll draw a
line here and let me just remind you
that i'm working on the second
derivative of f and that equals just to
simplify so 12x squared times X to the
fourth so that equals 12 X to the sixth
plus whatever 12 x 27 is so i'll just
write that down let's see if that's to
say well I don't feel like calculating
it right now so 12 times 27 12 x 27 x
squared minus 16 X to the sixth minus
16x 26 all of that all of that over X to
the fourth or X to the fourth plus 27
let me see does that simplify and all
this is 12 x 27 well anyway what can we
do now well we can 12 X to the sixth
minus 16 X to the sixth so what are we
left with minus four X to the sixth
let's welcome you let me let me figure
out what 12 x 27 is it's c 12 x 27 27 x
12 let's see it'll be 54 I don't want to
get all messy right here let me just get
the calculator out that's always
simplest get my calculator I should be
able do that in my head but it's hard
when you do it live 12 x 27 is equal to
3 24
so plus 324 man this would take your
like this is wasting paper if you have
to do on a notebook x squared x squared
all of that over X to the fourth plus 27
oh sorry this was squared right if we
were to take it from down there okay now
what do what was the whole point of
taking the second derivative well let's
let's answer the different parts of the
questions because I think we finally got
this would be secondary so let me erase
all of this here so we have some room to
work because now now that we've done
kind of our our mechanical part of the
work we can actually think about what
we've just done this was just our
getting to where we are now that just is
how we got to where we are now and
actually I can even erase this this is
the second derivative so i can erase all
of that work and hopefully you
understand how we got there and i can
even write it this is f prime prime of X
so let's do the first parts find the
intervals of increase in decrease so
essentially where is the first
derivative positive and when is it
negative so this is the first derivative
right so when is this term what is this
expression positive or negative what is
this expression so we could also written
this as 4x to the third over X to the
fourth plus 27 what is this positive and
when is this negative well first of all
the denominator is always going to be
positive right you take anything to the
fourth power it's automatically going to
be positive at least it's not not it's
not going to be negative right if you
put zero there you just get zero but any
other number there it's going to be
positive as long it's not imaginary so
the denominator is always going to be
positive so if you want to know what is
this positive or negative the question
only boils down to what is 4x to the
third positive or negative right and so
if you wanted to say when is it positive
well for four well for actually it's
it's kind of you know 4x to the third is
positive when X to the third is positive
and what is X to the third positive well
x is greater than zero right if you put
in any number greater than zero here
this term will be positive and likewise
when is this term negative well you put
a negative number you take you to the
negative to an odd number exponent
you're going to get a negative number so
let's say the intervals of increase so f
of X f of x increases when x is greater
than zero and how did we know that we
just looked at the first derivative and
we said when is this greater than zero
the denominator doesn't matter because
it's always positive so when is this
greater than zero when X to the third is
greater than zero when is it X to the
third greater than zero well sure when x
is greater than zero right only a
positive number to the third power is
positive and similarly and I'll write in
a different color f of X decreases when
X is less than zero because that's when
X to the third is less than zero which
will make 4x to the third less than zero
which will make this whole thing less
than zero and they didn't ask us for a
minimum or maximum point but the we do
have a critical point exactly when x
equals zero right because when x equals
zero we have the first derivative is
equal to 0 and and we have zero slope
and and we know whether that's a minimum
or maximum point well let's see f of x
increases when x is greater than zero so
the slope is upwards after 0 and f of X
decreases when X is less than zero so
slope is negative so right at x equals
zero we must have a minimum point they
didn't even ask us that but anyway so
let's figure out the intervals of
concavity and the inflection points now
so we know x equals 0 is a minimum point
we know when x is greater than 0 we're
increasing when X is less than zero
we're decreasing and now let's figure
out the conductivity and inflection and
that's where we're going to use this
second derivative and I let me erase all
of this just so we have some space to
work with let's see okay
this was a hairy hairy problem but in
the end all you have to do is chuck
through the algebra and have faith that
in the end something something vaguely
usable will come out so find the
intervals of concavity so what we want
to figure out is when is the second
derivative positive what is it negative
and when is it zero zero is inflection
point positive it means concave upwards
negative means it's concave downwards
and watch the the the previous three or
four videos I've done on on intuition of
connectivity and because I don't want
you just to memorize I want you to
always you know when you're when you're
50 years old or 40 years old and you
your kids are learning this I don't want
you to have to go back to the book I
want it to be ingrained you owe concave
up for it just means that the slope is
increasing so that means that the second
derivative must be positive right you
don't have to memorize these things but
anyway so let's figure this out when is
this what is this positive negative or
zero well we could use the same logic
this denominator is always going to be
positive right because no matter what
number you put in here you're going to
get either positive or zero and you get
left for 27 years square you're going to
get a positive number in the denominator
so f prime prime of X to the second
derivative is zero when this thing is
equal to zero when the numerator is
equal to zero it's positive when the
numerator is positive and it's negative
when the numerator is negative right
because this is just you know this is
always going to be positive down here so
let's figure out those intervals so
let's just figure out first of all when
this equals zero so minus four X to the
sixth plus 3 24 x squared let's figure
out when that equals zero well the first
thing I would do if we just list let's
just let's just divide both sides by x
squared just to get some you know get
this x squared another way so I get
minus four X to the fourth plus 3 24 is
equal to zero let's take the 4 X the
force on to that side of the equation so
we but then i'll switch swap sides of
the equation again so i get 4x to the
four
earth is equal to 3 24 right I just
moved it on that side and then switched
and i get x to the fourth is equal to
what's 3 24 divided by 4 is equal to 81
that's a good number and what to the
fourth power is equal to 81 well three
right because three squared is 9 9
squared is 81 so X and and this is
interesting though x is what x is equal
to plus or minus 3 right because minus 3
to the to the fourth power is also going
to be anyone so x is equal to plus or
minus 3 so these are the inflection
points x is equal to plus 3 and x equal
to minus 3 that's extra just the X
values if you wanted the actual
inflection points you would take you
would take f of both of those points so
let's see so the points if you actually
wanted the actual coordinate points for
the inflection points you would say
let's see you would say the point the
inflection points and I'll do them in
green green for inflection points
positive 3 and then you put three back
in here and the natural log of 3 to the
fourth which is 81 plus 27 81 plus 27 is
equal to what 108 it's the natural log
of 108 whatever number that might be
right that's one of the inflection
points if you were to graph that point
you could evaluate this on your
calculator and get the exact y value and
the other point is going to be minus 3
is going to be the same value right
because minus 3 the fourth is still 81
so it's also the natural log of 108 so
if you were to graph this on your
graphing calculator and I encourage you
to do so if you get the intuition these
would be two of the inflection points
and you would see it because we're going
we'd be going we'd be switching between
our connectivities then fair enough so
between these points we must be one type
of connectivity and then after these
points we must switch so let's figure
out what type of connectivity we are
between these points so what's a what's
a well actually no I just realized this
up here I shouldn't have just I should
just divided both sides by x squared I
should have just factored out an x
squared I should have said what does
this thing equal zero it's actually
sorry my mistake I should have written I
should have factored out I should have
said minus 4x squared I would redo the
video but I've gone so far into it that
I'll just carry forward and you'll see
them sometimes even I do simple
algebraic errors so if i were to factor
this out of it minus 4x squared times x
to the fourth minus 81 is equal to zero
so we solved when this equals zero right
this equals 0 when x is plus or minus 3
and then when else could this expression
equals zero well if this factor equal to
zero so if X is equal to zero so the
other inflection point we could say is
also zero right because if you put X
equal to 0 the second derivative is also
going to be equal to 0 sorry that was I
shouldn't have just divided both sides
by X square in fact in order to do that
you have to assume that X is not equal
to 0 so anyway I should have just
factored it out and then you say well is
either this is 0 or this is 0 my error
so the other inflection point is the
point 0 comma what well if you put 0
into the original equation you get the
natural log of 27 so these are the three
inflection points and so let's see I
think I'm I'm pushing 21 minutes so
those are the inflection points for this
and this was an extremely extremely
hairy problem so what are the continuity
so all you have to do to figure out the
connectivities is try x values in
between these points in between these
evaluate the second derivative at X
values in between those points and if
the second derivative is positive you
know it's concave upwards from you know
let's let me let me draw them on a
number line this might be the longest
video I ever made
the longest video I ever made so let's
see we get an inflection point at 0
positive 3 and negative 3 and we already
showed what these points are we could
graph on but that's too much time but
what happens it let's let's pick some
points are we concave upward or downward
here actually once we figure out once we
know that we keep switching at every
inflection point so that that's all we
know so let's try let's try x is equal
to 1 so at x equals to 1 what's F prime
prime of 1 f the second derivative of 1
is equal to what it's equal to minus 4
plus 3 24 so it equals 320 320 we don't
even care what the number is all we care
is that that number is positive right so
if the number is positive at one that
means from 0 to 3 from x equals 0 to 3
we are concave upwards and so every
inflection point we're switching so from
greater than three we are concave
downwards and then we're also concave
downwards over this interval and then
since we switch at minus 3 we're concave
upwards here well anyway this was a very
benign looking problem but it ended up
being much hairier than I thought and I
even made a simple mistake here but
hopefully that didn't throw you off too
much the simple idea is intervals of
increasing and decreasing when is the
slope increase when is the slope
decrease that's saying when does the
first derivative increase when does the
first derivative decrease conductivity
well the first thing you'd find is
inflection points that's what I would do
that's where the second derivative is
equal to zero this was extremely hairy
but we found those points and then the
actual points on the graph are these
three with the natural log etc and then
at these points you're switching between
connectivity upwards and downwards so
all you have to do is find the
connectivity at one of the points in the
interval and then at each of those
points they will switch and I encourage
you we don't have the time of this i'm
pushing 24 25 minutes but i encourage
you to graph that and verify and see for
yourself that the graphs really
are concave upwards for all X less than
3 and concave downwards between negative
3 and 0 and see what an inflection point
looks like what these points look like
anyway I'll leave it there and I will
see you in the next video